je ne veux pas crever du plus loin qu'il
m'en souvienne comme vous je ne je sais
que je vais mourir
quoique ce ne soit pas totalement urgent
mais je ne veux pas crever j'ai cette
force vitale en moi qui jaillit et qui
me dit oui tu vas mourir un jour
mais avant ta vie doit avoir du sens
elle doit être être riche et joyeuse
elle doit être belle elle doit être
plaide elle doit être choisie choisi à
ma naissance
j'ai rencontré la mort mon frère jumeau
est mort à la naissance et je suis
depuis toujours une survivante la survie
c'est fondamentalement mon mode de
fonctionnement survivre vous savez ces
gars toujours garder au moins un pied
dans la porte
anna faute disait que dans la vie comme
dans une partie d'échecs les premiers
coups sont importants il donne la
direction mais que ton que la partie
n'est pas terminée il reste heureusement
de joli coup à jouer
alors j'ai joué j'ai joué au fil des ans
avant d'être pleinement moi même
aujourd'hui j'ai accumulé des
expériences de vie des morceaux de vie
mais aussi vécu des petites morts d
enfermement
oui d enfermement dans des boîtes pour
mettre plier à ce que j'appelle des
choix dictés pour moi un choix dicté
c'est une illusion une injonction un
rôle un masque que les autres souvent
nous suggère où nous impose mais surtout
surtout que nous nous imposons à
nous-mêmes pour plaire pour être aimé
pour bien faire pour réussir
par mimétisme par conformisme par
confort le monde extérieur
la société les dogmes mais surtout mes
croyances et mes peurs montrent ainsi
fixer un cadre d'un parcours
ni bon ni mauvais mais qui n'était juste
pas le mien pas ma voix alors je les
endosser socialement professionnellement
émotionnellement comme une panoplie
nécessaire à mon bonheur
nos existences et une longue succession
d'étapes
nous sommes en travaux en construction
en permanence en cheminement sans en
connaître d'ailleurs ni la cartographie
numéraire et encore moi le lieu et la
date d'arrivée
selon un plan qui n'est pas
véritablement le nôtre dans un monde un
peu illusoire une chimère qui n'aura au
mieux que le goût du succès mais à
condition que je mette de côté mes rêves
et mon intégrité
on ça n'a pas eu que des inconvénients
j'ai vécu des aventures et des
existences parfois vaine mais aussi
parfois délicieuse dans le palais des
illusions c'est c'est aussi une étape
paradoxale du chemin vers la liberté
d'expérimenter nos propres entravent le
confort d'un carcan et d'y trouver aussi
du beau c'était une étape nécessaire à
mon éveil qui m'a fait me frotter à une
partie du monde donc je suis toujours en
mode survie mais désormais nourri par
l'accumulation d'expériences disons
chimérique
je me persuade que je dois être
quelqu'un avoir un rôle être un
personnage quitte à y perdre mon âme ma
flamme à devenir un mort vivant une
morte vivante un zombie mon identité mon
identité se révèle tributaire du regard
que je porte sur moi même et du regard
que les autres portent sur moi et je
suis comme beaucoup beaucoup d'entre
vous pétrifié par la peur d'être seule
d'être rejetée d'être abandonnée de
disparaître pourtant la mort l'ultime la
vraie c'est une disparition autrement
définitive on dit perdre la vie
mais avant nous avons affronté d'autres
disparitions des pertes effrayante
perdre son job perdre sa liberté son
autonomie sa santé alors les illusions
les masques les rôles les faux semblants
les interdictions les injonctions les
projections en encre est tous j'en ai
crevé et si on ne veut pas crever bien
qu'on sache qu'on va bien un jour mourir
il est vital de se sortir du chemin
obligé de s'incarner de se réanimer de
se désenclaver de se libérer des tu dois
aider on dit on est dit sois belle et
tais toi ou et surtout tétouan et j'ai
parlé je parle je parle je parle
notamment de cette mort qui nous est
tombé dessus il ya un an et qui nous
fait nous terrer avec de multiples
agonie à gaudi de la vie affective de la
vie sociale de la vie économique de la
vie culturelle mais aussi les
interdictions de bouger de s'étreindre
de choisir de se respire et de se sentir
cette mort concrète de 2,6 millions
d'êtres humains attribués au coc u19
depuis le début de la pandémie nous
heurte nous ne sommes pas éternels
c'est une évidence désormais nous ne
parlons jamais de la mort comme s'il
ignorait est une façon de l'occulté et
de l'éviter mais parler de la mort ne
tue pas joue là sur cette pandémie nous
rappelle qu'il faut intégrer la mort
dans nos vies dans nos projets de vie
parce que la mort n'est pas livré en
option à la naissance
la règle du vivant et que dès la
naissance la disparition de nos
premières cellules est programmée que le
renouvellement et notre programme nous
ne pouvons plus l'ignorer
nous sommes éphémère le sens de nos vies
notre je suis et éphémère aussi mais
magnifique paradoxalement parce que nous
sommes fragiles
et vulnérables oui je suis forte et
vulnérable car si je maîtrise certains
aspects de ma vie je ne contrôle pas ma
mort pas plus pas vie par contre je peux
les dessiner leur donner une forme me
redessinés ainsi il y a 6 ans j'ai été
dézinguer déchirée par un accident
opératoire la lésion de la moelle
épinière
mais par cette déchirure je suis né à ma
vie alors je vais vous rappeler un petit
truc en matière d'illusions quand on m'a
réveillé alors à 60 ans on m'a dit de
cet accident opératoire on m'a dit vous
ne remarcherait jamais plus j'étais fini
plus mr plus épouser plus femmes actives
plus personne plus rien et les autres
melon asséné mon ticket n'était plus
valable
au fond du trou dépendantes assisté
bonaria incapable invalides vieille en
plus à déposer dans un coin non vie
devant la télé à côté des plantes vertes
où j'étais devenu invisible
exfiltré de la société doublement
invisible par l'âge déjà et par le
handicap
je ne vais pas vous raconter à nouveau
ma rééducation
mon redressement moral et physique mais
deuil et mes choix ni vous dire que je
sais combien je peux encore souffrir est
tombé non ce que je veux vous dire c'est
qu'en mobilisant ce qu'il y a de plus
intime en moi en acceptant ce qui ne
peut pas être ce qui ne peut être
changée et en développant tous ceux qui
ne demandait qu'à éclore en meurent
respectant contrairement à ce que
prédisaient les pisse-froid normative et
frileux rien n'est impossible
au contraire je au contraire
je suis bien plus je suis debout je
marche à ma façon mais je marche je suis
écrivaine le rêve de mes 18 ans je
raconte des historiettes qui parle au
coeur des gens je suis connecté avec
toutes sortes de personnes à qui mon
respect de moi et mes forces vitales
font juste du bien et je vous remercie
je vous remercie d'être là pour moi et
je suis là pour vous ce soir des
injonctions des conseils des opinions
des autres j'en ai certes était par ci
des rôles des masques des projections
j'en ai plein mon vestiaire il m'a fallu
60 ans et des haies et des épreuves est
une épreuve pour comprendre qui je suis
aimé mais tel que je suis est désormais
accepter l'autre et les mets pour lui
même tel qu'il est je ne suis pas un
rôle modèle je ne suis pas un exemple je
suis une femme ordinaire imparfaite
comme vous proche de vous une femme
aligner coeur corps et esprit qui ne
regarde plus en arrière ou devant mais
je suis là ici et maintenant et
j'accepte que disparaisse de ma vie des
gens que j'ai pu et mais je ne donne à
personne le droit de disposer ou de
décider de pour moi notamment sur les
choix de vie et de mort je ne donne plus
la parole aux dégueulant à ceux qui
m'ont assuré que je ne remarcherait plus
et qu'à mon âge ma vie était finie les
dégueulant de tous bords mais ce sont
les mêmes aujourd'hui qui prédit des
prêts près prédisent la fin du monde et
balancent sur les autres leur peur leur
confusion mentale leurs angoisses leurs
fantasmes et surtout leur haine à
commencer par leur haine de même
personne
personne n'a besoin de dark vador mais
le monde a besoin de jedi
soyons tous des jedi ensemble nous le
valons bien vous le valez infiniment
parce que je n'accepte plus aujourd'hui
ce que j'ai accepté hier je suis devenu
mon propre jedi à la fois apprentis
maîtres de moi même et je suis convaincu
de votre capacité à être votre jedi
également redressons nous ensemble au
propre et au figuré
nous sommes nos propres limites nous ne
sommes victimes de rien ni de personne
nous pour les catastrophes en fait sont
souvent là pour nous éviter le pire
nous pouvons exister pleinement et
ensemble si tous et toutes nous nous
respectons comme vous je ne peux pas
tout avoir
je sais ce qui m'est essentielle je me
suis frotté à la réalité je vis
construite sur la blessure de l'amour
que je n'ai pas reçu à la naissance mais
sans attendre désormais que les autres
meurent et part je vis sur un fil avec
la paraplégie et la douleur mais debout
est attentive au monde
attentive à vous aussi auparavant
j'étais persuadé qu'il n'y avait pas une
minute à perdre
et pourtant il m'a fallu du temps tant
de temps en même temps sur le temps on
m'a dit tant de choses que j'étais trop
jeune fort longtemps qu'il fallait
attendre mon tour
on m'a dit tiens toi tranquille marche
dans les clous dit s'il te plaît et
merci on m'a dit c'est pour demain
franchement c'est nul et idiot l'âge de
saurait être un permis de vivre ni à 18
ans ni à 100 ans le droit d'exister
n'est pas fonction de l'âge
d'ailleurs à jour on a commencé à me
dire c'est un peu tard vraiment ainsi
d'art que cela voyez vous les copains
parce que ce soir ce que vous voyez je
ne suis pas une illusion
je suis une erreur statistique je
m'appelle nadal est
j'ai 65 ans je suis paraplégique
handicap invisible mais réelle je suis
femme publique et passeuse de mots alors
les oiseaux de mauvais augures vous
allez je vous enquiquiner personne ne
vit plus à ma place la guerrière à part
fait que je demeure ne se redresse que
pour ce qu'il a nourri intérieurement
avec passion et espoirs en me
réinventant dans un monde bercé lumière
parce que j'ai appris à me respecter à
mémé à prendre soin de moi je suis
capable
sincèrement d'aimer d'écouté de
respecter les autres
sans chercher à les sauver à tout prix
mais il faut s'aimer d'abord soi-même
pour pouvoir aimer l'autre l'amour et la
loi la seule ne vivent plus dans les
illusions des autres je vis dans mes
rêves qui sont ma réalité en paix debout
citoyenne et engagée comme un phénix
je suis comme vous une voyageuse de la
vie mais difficulté mes blessures parle
de votre ma joie simple dansante
contagieuse je vous la livre
ainsi je rencontre et vous pouvez aussi
rencontré votre part d'éternité qui
également fait de vos réussites et de
vos échecs et à jour il sera temps de
mourir n'est pas de crever
car ma vie est la vôtre vécu sans autres
limites que les nôtres avec authenticité
auront laissé un vrai sion et nous
serons prêts pour un nouveau voyage
merci